okay so hello I'm Andre and uh today I
will uh speak and show you some code
about how to create first of all
extensions in Rust python extensions and
then also how to communicate them with
python from rust using Asing iio which
might be the U natural way to
communicate
so uh so what I'll talk about today is
first of all I will tell you a few words
about Chaine Keepers which is my company
so what we do and uh where where I come
from then uh and then we'll focus on
performance of python and uh why it
might make make sense to uh try to
create extensions in something like rust
um and then about uh why this might be
particularly interesting in case of
network communication with web accounts
and then I will show you how this can be
done so uh chain Keepers that's uh my
company I work there also Milan over the
Airways there and uh we
basically said most simply well we
believe that
uh the decentralized finance really has
the potential to uh change the world for
the better and really uh shape many
aspects of our lives and what we do then
we
uh build trading Bots mostly at this
point in crypto but uh we view it more
broadly like a trying
to understand what things we could do to
stabilize def5 provide liquidity then
maybe also like uh provide some other
services to the decentralized economy so
uh we uh we are invested by mitton SE
and particularly on J rashka probably
some of you heard about them what we
mostly use rust and Pyon and we're
always looking for like people to talk
to who might be interesting in what we
do or perhaps then to work together so
uh definitely reach out if some of this
sounds
interesting
okay so uh now to the main point of main
theme of the talk so uh Python's really
speeding up and if it keeps like this
we're it just uh we just need to wait a
few more years and then we'll be at the
top performance of C++ but um uh really
uh python is maybe 50 to 100 times at
times slower than if you write
everything in in C++ for really
optimized which makes sense but it also
kind of sucks if you want to really
write fast code and do it in Python so
um one of the tools that can help you is
Numba who knows what Numba is or who has
used Numba like yeah so uh NBA helps you
if you have some some kind of long
computation that you write in Python and
then then you can speed it up quite
easily and in a straight forward Way by
using
Numba the other thing that slows python
down is abstraction which is really nice
to have like abstract code and not have
everything put in there uh and wir into
your code but every time you use
substraction in Python it costs you like
here some basic timings so uh if you
just have a no up statement it it runs
like 5 NS then if you do a call it takes
you 53 but if you do another call like
in the test class you see that there's
def call and the only thing that it does
is he calls like another call so if you
do like one dick L up on a class and
then a call it's maybe if you would do
two then it's twice as twice
as twice as much much time as a single
call so every time you use some kind of
abstraction it costs you uh
time in in a language like C++ this
might be optimized away and you wouldn't
even maybe do the other
call so uh basically
there then two main points where where
your python code can be sped up it's
like
uh maybe put away some of the
abstraction and not have have everything
Dynamic it's what Numba does maybe in
the in a loop but sometimes you want to
go through Python and uh process data in
a more structured way more often and
then Numba cannot really help you
because there's still some back and
forth communication with
python also there's this thing called
Jill who knows about Jill what Jill is
who could explain okay everybody so I
don't need to go into detail so
basically uh like every uh every
everything in Python is reference
counted and every reference counting has
to hold Jill so chill is practically
held all the time in Python so uh if you
want to like speed up code do it in a
threaded way then you cannot really do
it in by spawning multiple threads in
Python the only thing you can really do
is spawn multiple processes but then uh
it's it's kind of similar like Numba
maybe Numba you can use Numba about to
process smaller data but not really
small and you can use like if you want
to process really big data it's not a
problem because you just spawn multiple
processes and then process it in
parallel and then combine it all
together okay so uh what can we say
about R so python to wrap up
is easy not that fast at times there are
some ways to speed it up but just if you
have a lot of data processing uh in a
chunk so yeah I didn't start a timer but
yeah maybe like 30 minutes from now okay
so rust is a kind of a modern C++ I'd
say yeah and uh it can be quite
efficient uh I'm not that expert in in
this regard but even though rust is
quite new uh I found search for some
benchmarks and they say that like it
might be even faster than C sometimes
like so there is not really uh
performance penalty in Rust that would
be apparent like maybe in go or
something like that well go is not that
fast as C++ but rust is so uh rust also
enforces memory safety which uh all the
people that love rust they really love
this thing as well uh you might learn to
love it too if you do not really protest
what Russ is telling you that you need
to clone something and do it this way
then do it and then you'll be
fine so okay so and why why uh do I want
to talk about web
sockets and uh then uh how are we going
to to uh arrange the the next part of
the talk which is one thing the rust
extension and then some measurements
about how how it actually sped up the
code so uh uh in
uh in the blockchain analysis world that
that we do in chain Keepers uh we
usually have a lot of data sources in
small chunks of data which is and if you
want to process this in Python that you
are basically always in Python there's
not a lot of computation that you really
need to do at once so that you would uh
use so that you could use Numba there is
not a lot of if you maybe would span
spawn multiple processes and you would
introduce some networking overhead which
is not always what you want and you
definitely maybe don't have a large
chunk of data that you would need to
process maybe in some of the use cases
yeah but if you want to react to
something that is happening this would
not be the case so there might be a
little chunks of data and a lot of
concurrent sources that you need to read
from and then maybe imagine that you
want to eventually combine them into
some Global decision that you want to
act on and uh you do not want
necessarily to write everything in rust
from scratch because everything you
changed and you maybe need have to
change the design also at other parts of
the program which might be um costly it
might be correct but maybe it's not what
you're striving for at the first uh
prototyping phase and then uh but still
speed might be of concern to you so you
don't want to like just use Python let's
let's python is ideal but you would like
to speed it up somehow so uh how do how
do I approach this so uh how could you
speed this up that was the idea and then
uh we'll see if it really speeds things
up uh one of the things that really
slows up Json files or Json processing
which are really abundant in the
blocking world is parsing of
Json it's kind of fast in Python but
maybe it could maybe you could do better
and also um The Next Step of this thing
would be to maybe write some custom
parsers which might be even faster but
in Python this makes no sense because
you couldn't really do that
so uh maybe you want to pass an
aggregate data in Rust and then pass it
to python somehow um okay so uh this is
uh RWS that's how I call the extension
that I'll be showing to you and uh so I
will talk about the python part then I
will talk about the rust uh Rust part
and for the python module for the rust
rust module in Python we use P3 I won't
be really like describing it in any
detail but here is a link if uh you will
then browse through and the code will be
available on GitHub um it is uh it is
available on our GitHub CH GitHub I will
re say it again at the end of the top
there's the QR code you can search for
it okay and uh in Rust I use Tokyo async
framework I'm not sure I can really tell
a lot about it there are multiple
Frameworks for async in Rust I don't
really know how they differ or how this
would apply to to this uh talk it's just
everybody uses Tokyo so I use it to like
I think iio and python they're also like
multiple Frameworks
but okay so um the python part so
um okay so for the pon part um what what
we want to have so we want to have a
okay so this is a python this is
description I will not now describe how
how the module is laid out show some
code just to to introduce talk a little
bit about the code I don't know if it
will be intelligible uh if there are
some questions please ask and uh we'll
see and uh other than that it will just
show how the general layout is and then
you can look it up in GitHub and maybe
run the code play with it a little bit
try to change
things okay so so the python part I will
start from the python part the python
part wants to just uh get some stream
that is published from rust and in
Python you just want to like have some
kind of easy um easily usable stream and
then run this in a nicing iio
loop and then U then you consume the
data and measure the latencies what the
the measurement maybe I will describe
also how the measurement is laid out out
laid out I have some python server like
a really simple script that just
generates data and sends some kind of
data and the Tim stamp and then the
consumers then I have a pure python
consumer R pure Russ consumer and then I
have python with the rust module and I
just connect to the python server that
really just send data at intervals and
then read the data and compare the times
time when it was generated at the server
and the local time and then I see how
long it takes to get there so there's
obviously the network Laten latency then
there's some Jitter because the pilent
really is not multipress like multi-read
it but then there's some systematic
difference between the
implementations okay so uh so in Python
what you want to do basically is you
have like cor main Loop you run it asyn
IO basically what it does it just
instantiates a stream that's now the
stream in
Rust I'll describe later how it is done
and then then you just call stream run
it runs the stream opens the wind opens
the zokas starts a thread in Rust which
is now now rust is in uh it's a module
so you will have to thread two threads
in in Python but uh the one thread it
doesn't really touch jail so it can run
its own way it's like its own life and
then python operates uh in the second
thread in the main thread and then when
the Rust part wants when the r module
wants to communicate with python it will
like communicate through some some acing
stuff like some through the queue how I
will show later and uh only then it
needs to obtain jail communicate with
the queue and then it's then uh easy
doing its uh job so and in the in the
python consumer it's like simple acing
for data in stream and you consume it we
say like uh the rust had put their X
time which is the creation time and then
we obtain our own time then print it and
I have like logs and then I analyze the
the delays the task done it's just uh
it's not really necessary but you could
really the Q Q thing is as we'll see uh
stream Q is a acing IQ that was created
from Russ but it's a general ASN IQ
object like a python object and you can
easily call anything on it from
python okay so uh so we have a main so
there was this blank this is a stream
implementation in Rust we're starting
from the back but from the more familiar
things so I I think it's more
intelligible so uh for a python for the
python to know what stream is he needs
to to have a module so stream will be
defined in an ear module here we have P
Stream So P stream is implemented in
Rust so that's the that's the extension
and uh for the extension you need a shed
library and then you need a pi f file
that's this one and the pi file really
does like just say what is there for
python so there's an init and there's
run and we have attribute URL Q simple
so we have P Stream So from this P
stream we will create something in
Python so there is a stream wrapper that
enables us to then do the async
iteration which would be
here right this thing so I have a p
stream that's from rust P stream is a
rust module
um now I have stream and uh it is a
rapper he has stream and Q and then this
thing this get outter really creates
just a proxy so everything I can call
everything I call on stream that I don't
have defined is forwarded to to the rest
uh
part and then I have the iterator here
so I can do um the main Workhorse is snc
I ke so I will wait on the Q until there
is something there and then I will yield
it in the async iterator if there is an
exception I will I will raise an
exception so rust does not really raise
exceptions on its own he just passes it
through the stream and if python sees an
exception phrases this is quite
arbitrary so now we have a pythonic
field for a class so uh we have a we
have a uh webset
stream implemented in Rust that can be
really easily consumed in Python so what
uh what do need to provide on the Rust
part rust
side so rust will do aning uh like now
it is async rust async webz connection
and then uh if it has some data we'll
send it to python through the
queue and U yeah then you need python
bindings and also you need a
sh
um okay so uh let's start from the end
again from the simple things so first uh
the whole uh rust build system is built
around kago and uh this is here just
to just to show that uh really uh all
that you need to create a python shared
library is uh you need to for it to have
a name and then you put
there CDI lip
and then it creates a shed
library and this is basically all then
then you have some dependencies later on
but this is the build for
rust okay and then then you need lip RS
which would be like the implementation
of the library and
uh again uh in the code and GitHub this
is like at the end of the of the whole
module but it's uh it's again the the
simplest things first so uh here it's uh
python sorry his rust function that does
uh the initialization of the module so
uh as I was saying we're using pio3 it's
a framework and rust for to WR python
modules and it provides all those kinds
of uh nice macros so um who here has
seen
rust or used rust okay so uh five for
people so
uh so in so let me describe this a bit
so in Rust hash uh something is a macro
the macro basically can act on uh no
this this is De Rider or a macro and it
can then act on on the code and rewrite
it somehow or write some other code uh
so the the pi module is from P3 and P3
we name this uh lip uh ruw us and p 3
manages
to he sees this as some kind of
initialization code and on loading the
python interpreter will load a library
and then he needs to run some
initialization code to make the symbols
and classes and everything available to
the python runtime so this is how we
create it automatically and the only
thing we need we need to initialize some
kind of
logging and then if we have a class
which we'll see that is defined later uh
we just use really simple like uh m is
this Pi module that we obtain from from
the framework and we just add class
simple and if we want to add exception
we need to Define exceptions beforehand
you you can look it up in the code it's
also like oneliner simple macro call you
just Define exception and here you addit
stream ended exception it's like stream
ended this is would this would be the
rust Rust part and then you register it
for
python so uh also some Rust uh rust
things or one one thing in in uh pile
three there's this
python thing like Pi python that's
everywhere and it's written here like
that's uh just represents the jell lock
so all all of all the interactions in p
3 with python they usually need this Pi
python object that represents that you
obtain the Gill we'll see how you can
obtain it but here the framework
obtained it for us and he just it just
passes to us and so we just can add to
the module then get the type
everything's okay so some Rust specifics
also uh in Rust you don't have
exceptions so uh um every function can
signal errors but uh it signals Errors
By values so if a function can fail it
always returns result so this is by
result there are multiple variant of
results which gets quite of annoy kind
of annoying at least for me but yeah you
can then convert and uh but if you don't
know how to convert and it fails but
here is no problem because the the
framework really understands by result
and uh if if something fails he he sends
an error uh and if everything passes
here we have okay notice that this line
does not have a semicolon all the other
lines have it so if you add a semicolon
it's a statement if you don't this is a
return value so uh the the only thing
that does not have it is a return value
if he would add it here he would
complain that there's no return value
because you consume it and also R thing
there is this uh question mark question
mark is a magic thing in Rust because
basically everything can uh as there are
no
exceptions uh a lot of the functions
signal Errors By uh being either okay or
being
error but uh if uh at every line you
would have like match call okay error
then you would be like really unreadable
so if you don't really care or don't
want to handle the error you just add
the question mark and if it's
a if it results in an error the whole
function will end in an error and if
it's okay then it just uh falls through
to the next line so
yeah okay so there was a bit of rust and
also this is uh really simp so
registering the module really simple
from the rust um if you have the objects
in R
simple any questions maybe
or okay maybe I have a question so how
doesch looks like if anything fails on
one of these lines oh can I when it
happen
well well okay uh in Rust uh basically
the type Checker usually like tells you
that it does not compile so uh if if it
can fail somewhere uh the one thing is
that it does not compile and if if there
is an error that falls through I guess
you would uh get it uh during
loading but I haven't seen it so but you
can try and you can take the code and
then
maybe replace this with error and uh see
what fails but I would expect that the
python would fail somehow upon
loading or maybe he maybe he converts
the RS into exceptions somehow uh
transparently I'm not sure about
this okay so uh so this was the
registering so uh the next thing now I
have a main RS but this is actually not
main from the module this is main from
the rust implementation and it's here to
show how you would uh do the loop in
Rust like uh the consumer part where
where it connects to a web soet and then
does something with it and then maybe
ends
so
initializes logging then you you have
like M macro calls end with a bang so if
there is in Rust again if there is a
bang at end of of
a identifier it is a macro so a macro
there's some some kind of rewriting
language he sees all the tokens that you
pass in it's not really rust but it's
just some kind of macro language
manipulating with tokens and then there
is some result and then it tries to
compile
it um I'm not really sure why it's
needed here but basically mostly because
of the conversions of the types
they don't really happen automatically
in Rust so you would use some kind of
micro okay so this thing then spawns a
coroutine in the Tokyo framework this
would be like a like uh asnc iio
loop what is it called start TKS
oh like in Python you you would just
start dusk like not not awaiting it but
starting it like um concurrently that's
what this
does and so he starts this the move is
needed because of uh rust move semantics
I won't go into detail uh at this line
so this starts a cortin connect which
really connects to the web soet then W
data and then prints it and
uh this one sleeps and here is a weight
so this is might be similar to if you
would do in Python like spawning a task
and then wait like waiting forever until
you're
done B it this is the Rust
part okay so how could connect
look how would connect L okay so we have
a URL what's interesting here like we
use th night to connect and then there
one interesting rust thing you see that
all uh the eror handling is quite for
both in Python maybe we just hope that
it will succeed or throw an exception
and be okay with it here you need to
react or because otherwise you cannot
really get the data from from the scent
you might be okay by putting there the
question mark but otherwise not if you
have the next next part so now you
connect it and uh you would use
connection next similar to python await
really does does the similar
things and then you get data you need to
parse Jason
data here I have a note like there uh
there's a parser and if you would parse
uh Jason's in Rust maybe we' use her the
Json some kind of General structural
data parer uh it uh it was um
well it was really slow if I FedEd a lot
of data it was really slow so uh part
Jason Parts didn't have that problem so
maybe if you want to have uh no don't
care so much about the structure but
care about the speed maybe this
is
better okay so now here here we have
data uh now where did we obtain it here
like uh there's data so if I have had
like I had some item this could also be
like in python
or is um how could I like in Rust you
can have this Le does implicit pattern
matching so uh from the a weight you can
either get some or none if there is no
data if you get none you get a
failure but here it's like always data
so and the data is item then if it's
text you parse it here if it's okay so
the the item can again be some kind of
error so if it's an error you don't do
this if it's a text you parse it and if
it's some anything else you assume it's
an error you just print it and terminate
the connection so now we have in data we
have our our data that we want to
process further so
uh okay so and here here here comes the
interesting python connection part so I
have my
data and
uh I par data time which is like an
really arbitrary data format there's
that's the time that the server uh
created the data I want to compare that
time to the local time so have this time
get time stamp and now I need to
interact with python so I need to obtain
gel I can do this by
python with Jill and then he calls
disclosure he obtains Jill and calls
disclosure with pi and to create a
dict uh this might be elaborate but this
feels kind of nice so I just pass list
of topples and then call into P dict and
what he really does he creates some kind
of python object and also sets it up to
be reference counted in Python and then
like increases the reference
count the nice thing is that working
with reference counted data might be at
times way simpler than caring about the
rust copy move semantics because if it's
reference count it is something kind
like kind of a it is kind of a smart
pointer in like smart pointer in C++ so
basically every time you pass it you can
freely cop it clone it and rust and he
just increases the reference count the
only bad thing about this is if you want
to interact with the reference uh with
the reference count you need to Jill so
you cannot really use some kind of Clone
in Rust you just need to call again to
ref or to object and pass it with the
piie you will see this maybe in the code
on GitHub so if you have the dict then
we have some kind of Q which we'll look
more into that's some kind of wrapper
around the python python Q to be usable
in Rust and like be possible around and
not violate the memory constraints and
then we have some method push P it's
also a method I will show how it is
implemented and just push the
data he he needs uh the method to
interact with the Q we also need Jill
and we also we already have Jill here so
we just uh pass it along so that's how
the interface is designed and with the
data okay so now now more in the how the
que could be implemented so that's
that's this thing the the Q Q in the
code before here this Q is this kind of
object so it's uh it's uh Pi I think
Q struct in Rust and uh we have a few
methods do implemented this is a new
method so this method instantiates the
pi a
q um what it does at the end so how
the
it the string so you need construct new
string new python string in Rust again
Jill and then put now way so this is
really a call that would in Python you
would just say get other Q uh put no
weight and here you can write it like
this call Tre say that there was
something similar but way longer so I
just uh didn't put it in the slide and
then I save
Q uh to build Q I need to call python so
that's here above so uh again I need
Jill I obtain it like before and then um
I really like this for some for some
reason like uh you just copy that it's
not not a big deal so you need to import
ASN IQ and then uh then just EV all q
and you get Q um then you need to run
into Pi which really from the rust kind
kind of object you will get a new
reference increased reference count so
that you can keep it that's that's this
thing and then you can put it put it in
here otherwise you wouldn't be able to
do
that and get running Loop something
really similar like this thing it just
calls async iio get running Loop and uh
so that we can query Callum threat Save
which is what we'll need later on and
save
it so um this is how we construct P Pi
aing q and then what we also needed was
q and we need Push by so how is Push by
defined so push
by uh it's a method on the Q so it uh
rust gives us self which we can then use
it's a reference to self then also we
defined it so that we already have Gill
so that we don't have to reobtain it
again so we have this Pi thing and then
we have some kind of value
and that the value can be converted to
Pi object this is like set with this and
then uh so uh in Python what do we want
to do we want to do uh call soon thread
save and then Q push no8
data if it was Python and if it's since
it's rust we need to convert the value
to python object but we already have uh
the reference is to put no weight we
already obtained it before and we have a
reference to call Tread safe also so and
call1 is just a just a P3 so the
framework's way of saying like we need
to call
it so
uh to wrap it up basically what what I
just described
is you have
a you can have General any kind of
processing in Rust and then if you want
to communicate G back to python you just
really you just really
uh use a que and push it there in kind
of python
way so and now then then I was uh
interested in whether this actually
helps with anything or or whether there
is uh well there might be a few things
going wrong right or or go wrong like um
either the
the parsing part on the python side
might not be that bad and the overhead
not that large so that you wouldn't
really notice uh how rust how much rust
speed things speeds things up or it
could happen that if you would have pure
rust implementation that would be really
fast but if you would just write a
module that would communicate with
python anyway then a lot of uh the
overhead would come from the
communication to rest uh
to from rust to python back so you would
uh anyway not get any Improvement and
you would need
to just Implement everything in Rust and
discard python all together if you would
uh need speed so um so how was The
Benchmark done I already described this
a bit at the beginning so there was a
python server feeding some data some
Json data points at 10 milliseconds each
and then there was a pure python code
which used or Json which is kind of a
fast test Json parser I know of then
there was a pure rust implementation
that used this Json rust parser and then
there was some uh and then there was
this uh rust module but the the final
consumer was python who would time stamp
and print the the latency information
the module also used rust Json
and then I measured differences between
the times like the server created the
data time stamp it and the client read
the data parsed it time stamp it and
then printed out the results also the
printing could have affected uh the daa
and uh I would imagine that this might
also be real like a this would
uh penalize all python uh or all the
python clients right because in in Rust
you would be really able to print fast
but in Python no uh and it would not
depend whether you use rust for to get
the data or not because the print would
be slow so um okay so uh results so for
the data I have time stamp and then I
had 300,000 of a in an array Jason like
a long data array whatever and uh I let
it run for 10 minutes and then I uh
compare the logs so uh here what you can
see this is the pure python
implementation this is pure rust and
this is the rust module in Python you
can see that uh basically the rust and P
python
module well the the rust and rust module
are pretty close which was kind of
surprising um because I expected there
would be more um
penalty here and
uh okay so python six times slower I
expect it like to be more slow but
possibly it's like there was this
network also effect and uh it's really I
think that it it has sense just to
compare on the variance and not really
draw any general conclusions about this
so uh but
the the
penalty like the the the time of com
communication
from rust to python seemed not to be
really bad like uh maybe like on a
really on a scale of a function goal
which like also see seems too little but
it's what the data
says I could also tried with smaller
data which would be more realistic to
our use case because we don't really
have such big data blobs it's really
possibly like a blockchain transaction
would be
maybe
like 100 characters maybe 100 to 300
characters in total
Json so uh I tried with five a in an
array so really it was just a time stamp
not not really longer and then maybe 5 a
and here U the Python and the r module
really seem close so so but the py but
the but here um the difference is not
that bad like before with the big data
python was really slow like if you would
if you were only using Python and then
you would use the module you would get a
really big speed up here not so
much but anyway
uh uh anyway uh the approach works it
seems so uh so there were two uh aims
this like first explore how you could do
this uh there might be also other use
cases to write rust
modules in uh for the blockchain
application there are some protocols
that only have B bindings to rust so you
don't really you you want to use rust
just for the sake of having some kind of
integration possible but also for speed
up this can be
used so uh the python rust overhead is
not that big expected more and uh okay
so uh it seems you don't really need to
give up prototyping and you can just
rewrite parts of your code and rust and
then uh gain speed and uh um remember
that simpler is usually
faster okay